i want to start with the most important
question
um which probably doesn't pertain to
many people but it affects me
you'll notice i'm very white and i'm
just curious what is the secret to
making a movie on a beach
in a bathing suit and not getting
sunburned
a lot of sunblock when i say a lot i
mean like
completely smothered in layers and
layers and layers of it because
as you can see i too am very pale um
and some and my mum would have killed me
if i had gotten
horribly burnt so um yeah sunblock
hats sunglasses and all of it
yeah i've just wondered because you're
in the sun that whole movie and i'm like
how did she not get
sunburned i was kind of amazed too i'm
not quite sure
i'm not quite sure why how i didn't get
burnt um
but i guess in new zealand the sun is
very strong there's a layer missing in
the
in the in the ozone layer there's a hole
so maybe my skin was just like used to
really intense rays
um yeah sure uh i love learning about
the behind the scenes
of the making of a movie what do you
think uh might surprise people to learn
about the making of old
we were really up against the elements i
think
um filming on a beach during the
hurricane
season and which is something like i've
never experienced before
and so before we even started filming
there was
um some insane weather and part of the
set got pulled out of the sea and so
they had to rebuild it
um just yeah being on the beach in the
sun
for long hours um was
a big challenge but it was also really
cool to kind of get through it with the
with
the rest of the cast and the whole crew
and yeah
also just like such a wonderful place to
be filming
um on that beach amid so much nature
and it was really exciting and the set
was so incredible with all the rocks and
everything that they had
built by the way congratulations on the
movie i really enjoyed it
um and i was thinking about it the next
day completely sidebar
uh what has it been like for you uh the
last like year or two maybe i think
that's two years like landing cool
project after cool
project it's been amazing um
it's been very surreal and it all kind
of it happened really fast it was like a
snowball kind of like rolling down the
hill and building and building and
building
so when the pandemic hit it was um
and everything kind of came to a screech
to a standstill it was
a bit of a shock to kind of reflect on
the past couple years and and realize
how much had happened in
such a short period of time um similarly
to the film
kind of i don't know like just like the
the themes of time and aging
and and all of that so um yeah it's been
a real crazy journey but
i'm just so excited to to be where i am
and to be
to be working and to be doing what i
love i just wrapped
um a series called life after life that
i had the most
incredible experience on so i just have
like i don't know
i just want to keep on going and keep on
acting and working it's just
it makes me so happy and
i don't know so i'm really very excited
i have to stop there i'm just going to
say congratulations and obviously i'm
incredibly excited for edgar wright's
movie as well
yes so i can't wait for you to see it